hey guys it is the eighth of April my
name is Jess McDonald and you're
watching games but news the premier
gaming news show on the whole internet
that's hosted by an Australian and
produced out of Sydney are we do again
it seems you can prepare for an
innovative gears of war and no that is
absolutely not a typo Microsoft have
promised that the upcoming gears game
from their new first party studio black
tusk will bring a new flavor to the
franchise Microsoft Studios director Ken
lab has told edge I actually have a lot
of respect for all the guys up it's like
task I think the reality is that what we
have is an innovative Gears of War
that's what I believe they're going to
make we don't have any further
information on what's making the game so
damn innovative but love did say that
some of the concepts being worked on for
the title are quote awesome and that's a
seal of approval if I've ever heard one
let me know whether you reckon this
gears installment will actually deliver
on the innovation Peter Molyneux has had
some harsh words for the kinect today
including referring to the inclusion of
the device as a joke the fable designer
explained I actually wish connect wasn't
a requirement it feels like an
unnecessary add on to me maybe it's
because we're in England and it doesn't
really use the TV stuff but it feels
more and more like a joke he went on to
say that he thinks the camera itself is
finicky in regard to when it doesn't
doesn't work and thinks Microsoft could
reduce the cost of the xbox one by
releasing a version without connect in
fact he said it would be unthinkable
that they wouldn't give ease of have
most watchdogs and you play today to the
dismay of many fans anticipating the
awaited action game Ubisoft confirmed
that the pc version of watch dogs will
require that you play platform to be
installed and that's whether or not you
buy the steam version AUB rep told IGN
that they're going to use uplay to
support the game services a fairly
unpopular move given that you play seems
to have a favorability rating that just
barely beats out origin the pc spec
requirements have also been released and
they're pretty meaty soph you want to
check out just how the game will run on
your pc you can get all the nitty-gritty
details from our story on gamespot now
personally I am NOT a fan of the you
play client or many clients but let me
know whether you're upset about this
ruining your watchdogs experience or
whether you're just happy to roll with
it either in that comment section down
below well you can do so on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald those are all
the things that I have to say to you
today but be sure to leave me all your
thoughts and feelings on today's stories
and I'll have a bunch more news for you
tomorrow